jurassic world dominion is the thrilling
conclusion to the second jurassic
trilogy but it doesn't wrap everything
up into a neat bow what's the villain's
ultimate plan what's next for dr wu keep
watching for the biggest unanswered
questions in dominion
by the end of jurassic world dominion
the governments of the world have
decided that the remaining dinosaurs
under biosin's care will continue living
in the valley in italy's dolomite
mountains which will become a natural
preserve for the animals this comes of
course after biosins fall from grace
leaving the land free and available what
the film doesn't address however is
exactly how the preserve will be
maintained in the context of all the
other dinosaurs out in the world biosin
was keeping their own stock of creatures
on hand sure and the surviving dinos
will be free to stay there but what does
that mean for the wild dinosaurs who've
adapted to whatever climate they've
settled in at this point will world
governments designate special teams to
round up those dinosaurs and resettle
them in the preserve will some dinosaurs
simply be allowed to roam the wild
forever as part of a larger mission of
coexistence whether fans get a sequel or
not the implications of this preserve in
the larger franchise story are
fascinating
midway through dominion it is revealed
that maisie lockwood is not just a clone
of the late charlotte lockwood but
actually her daughter born through a
means of asexual reproduction with her
genetic code corrected from charlotte's
to eliminate a congenital defect maisy
is therefore the key to a puzzle
involving biosin's swarms of genetically
engineered superlocus because her dna
could help create a pathogen that kills
them maisie's importance throughout
dominion is well established but what
viewers still don't know is what other
applications her unique genetic makeup
might offer her brilliant mother was
able to create her through genetic
manipulation alone which could open up
new reproductive avenues for infertile
women her unique dna could also give
scientists clues to curing any number of
diseases so is maisie the rosetta stone
for all manner of cures could the wonder
of her existence be replicated is she
destined to be studied for the rest of
her life all in the name of saving more
people it's up in the air but by the
time the film ends maisy is in the
unique position of being the most
valuable human being on the planet
you shouldn't use my name
dotson
dotson we've got dodson here
jurassic world dominion recasts and
reintroduces the villainous lewis dodge
sun played by campbell scott this time
around dodgson is a long time rival of
john hammond who has now made his
company biosin the biggest corporate
presence in the dinosaur realm with the
help of dr henry wu dodgson has set up a
state-of-the-art facility devoted to
studying dinosaurs and their dna he's
also in secret developing super locusts
to devour crops around the world with
the goal of selling his own company's
seeds as a locust proof alternative this
plan backfires of course and by the end
of the film dodge sun is dead and his
company has been exposed as corrupt
viewers know that various major players
in the film including alan grant and
ellie sadler are set to tell both
congress and the press about biosin's
issues but the question remains what
else was dodgson working on he was
ambitious and ruthless enough to mess
with food supplies after all so what
about water supplies what about invasive
plant species to alter other ecosystems
to suit his needs the film digs deep
into the problems of biosin but it's
also clear by the end that we've only
scratched the surface of dodgson's
schemes
at one point late in the film dr henry
wu approaches the heroes and asks them
for help only to have dr ian malcolm
point out that historically wu has been
at least one of the sources of every
problem in the franchise all of this
exists
because of me the legendary geneticist
has had his hand in engineering just
about every dangerous dino species
walking the earth at this point so why
should they trust him well it turns out
that wu might be the only guy who can
stomp the locust plague so they give him
a hand he stops the locust plague and it
all works out
but wu still deserves some sort of
consequences for his role doesn't he
this is a guy who spent years designing
dinosaurs by fusing their dna with
various reptiles and who has now spent
at least the last little while designing
custom killer locusts for biosim at best
he's a dangerous man who needs to be
disbarred restricted ostracized and or
stopped from further experimentation at
worst he's a criminal who should be
locked away regardless of whether he's
learned his lesson and despite how
charming and quirky bd wong makes the
character wu has to own up to some of
those sins the question is how
by the time of dominion dinosaurs have
spread out around the globe inhabiting
just about every continent in some form
or another and becoming either a
nuisance or an outright hindrance to
human life some see this as an
opportunity and they are manipulating
things for their own gain biosin is
front and center of course but there are
hints other people are custom breeding
dinosaurs to make them into killing
machines with poachers picking up
dinosaurs for breeding purposes to sell
as pets or worse by the end of the film
there's a concerted effort to create a
new sanctuary for the creatures but that
doesn't mean the poachers and the
breeders are just going to go away the
question is how many of them are still
out there and how far will they go in
order to protect their hustle
speaking of those breeders it's clear in
dominion that certain aspects of
dinosaur adjusted life from jurassic
world fallen kingdom have only grown in
the intervening years early in the film
we meet santos played by dichen lochmann
santos is a bounty hunter of sorts who
has been tasked with getting her hands
on maisie for dodgson and biosin in the
course of her mission santos introduces
us to a group of specially bred raptors
trained to target anything identified by
a laser pointer and hunt it these
raptors have a relatively small role to
play in the overall film but their
presence reminds us that various
interests around the world are still
devoted to making sure dinosaurs can be
deployed as powerful weapons something
those rich powerful people in fallen
kingdom were keenly interested in what
are you doing this animal is not for
sale look if you want to create an
addict you have to give them a taste the
question now under the new status quo at
the end of the film is how far that
effort will go will we eventually see
mercenaries and even standing armies
fighting alongside dinosaurs will larger
carnivores be drafted into hunting duty
will herbivores become beasts of burden
the longer dinosaurs exist in our world
the more likely such possibilities seem
although they have continued to work
with dinosaurs on their own in the years
since fallen kingdom claire and owen
begin dominion living in relative
seclusion doing their best to help out
while devoting a lot of energy to taking
care of maisie and keeping her existence
a secret the film's early scenes show us
that they're struggling as her adoptive
parents not just because she's
rebellious but because they've been
thrown into the roles and are still
doing their best to adjust by the end of
the film both claire and owen have grown
into their parental roles with maisie
they've embraced their need to protect
her in a more emotional way and pushed
themselves to new heights in their
journey to get her back no matter what
they've also spent even more time around
dinosaurs and proven instrumental to
dismantling biosim so what do they do
now well they keep working with
dinosaurs in a more direct way training
some of them while advocating for the
safety and care of others will claire's
administrative gifts come back into play
now that there's a sanctuary devoted
entirely to dinosaurs well they finally
get to take a break when it's clear that
maisy is no longer in danger whatever
their future may hold it's clear that
life in hiding isn't necessarily
something they have to deal with any
longer
the most anticipated dominion element
perhaps was a reunion of the original
jurassic park stars marking the first
time in three decades that grant settler
and malcolm were all sharing the screen
together it's a big deal and that proved
especially true when it came to the
development of alan and ellie's long
dormant relationship by the end of
dominion alan and ellie have once again
been on a massive dinosaur-filled
adventure together and their respective
single statuses mean there's nothing in
the way of a romantic reconciliation at
last alan grant seems willing to settle
down with the woman he loves and ellie
is open to the kind of wandering life
alan's embraced for so long it makes
them a seemingly perfect pairing
so what happens now obviously they're
both going to do some work with congress
to make sure another biosin can't emerge
from the ashes of the film but what's
after that will they go back to full-on
paleontology digging up dead dinosaurs
rather than studying live ones will they
keep traveling the world or settle in
one place for a quieter study wherever
they go it's clear they'll be together
you coming or what
a lot has changed in the time since the
original jurassic park film but one
thing that has not is the philosophical
outlook of dr ian malcolm a naysayer who
was convinced the dinosaur dna project
was a bad idea from the very beginning
malcolm has spent the last three decades
being proven right time and again your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think they should
now in dominion he's taken a job as a
corporate philosopher at biosin just for
the hefty paycheck it provides and is
more than happy to lecture everyone
about the oncoming collapse of human
civilization in ian's eyes our species
has brought about the mechanism of its
own extinction so there's really nothing
left to do but rearrange the deck chairs
on the titanic by the end of dominion
however there seems to be at least the
appearance of hope in the world dr wu
has used his genetic prowess for good
the dinosaurs are protected and the
chance of peaceful coexistence seems
imminent with all that in mind it's
worth asking has dr malcolm's view of
the world changed did his speech about
the power of genetic manipulation and
wielding it wisely make him think that
perhaps the right people are finally in
charge or is he still convinced we're
all doomed
over the course of the film maisie
lockwood goes on a journey of
self-discovery in which she learns that
she's far more than just a copy of
another person she's not a clone at
least not exactly but rather a daughter
of a real mother who not only gave birth
to her but advanced her genetic code to
give her a better chance at a full life
the more maisy learns who her mother was
and what she was able to do the more she
feels like she knows herself and the
more she feels like she has a life worth
living the question now is what does
maisie do next she's still interested in
working with dr wu at least to the
extent that she helped solve the locus
problem so will she want to keep doing
that work in the future will she follow
in her birth mother's footsteps and
become a brilliant scientist with an eye
toward solving the problems of the
future will she pursue a different field
entirely the possibilities seem endless
but it's clear that maisie has a much
deeper sense of self than she did as the
film began
here's one for the longtime jurassic
park fans near the end of dominion as
louis dodgson realizes his plans are
crumbling he packs up his data and beats
a path out of town on a hyperloop train
at one point he reaches for a battered
dirty old barbasol shaving cream can and
puts it with the rest of his things fans
will recognize this as a nod to his
appearance in the original jurassic park
film as played by cameron thor when the
character gave nedry a barbasol can
hollowed out to hold vials for dinosaur
embryos as part of his plan to steal
hammond's cloning tech
750
on delivery 50 000 more for each viable
embryo that's 1.5 million if you get all
15 species off the island it's a nice
nod to the original film but how did
dodgson get the can back in the first
place in jurassic park it's seemingly
lost when nedry is attacked by a dyno
and left to die was there some sort of
tracking device in it that meant dodgson
could eventually find it did someone
just happen across it and figure out it
was his however he came to possess it
once again it's clear that little ken
has been through a lot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]